hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the Croatian
Grantchester being played in Zagreb it's
the final round and it's Magnus Carlsen
versus Maxime Barcia holograph it's
still a race anyone can take the
tournament will not anyone either Magnus
or Wesley will take the tournament in
Magnus has to either draw the game
against Maxime and then maybe Wesley
will win against Levin and then they
will have a playoff tomorrow or if
Magnus is able to win his game against
Maxie Marshall grabbed an Magnus as he's
the sole leader before the final round
will take the tournament so without
further ado let's just check it out
Magnus opens with d4 sorry about that
with nice to have six by Maxine c4 g6
Knight to c3 and d5 we have the groom
full defense which is super exciting as
maxime beaugeois Grove
you know his other specialties is known
as a world-class specialist in the groom
full defense
I don't know always thought Peter
Svidler was the the you know biggest
well a most knowledgeable personal
person about the groom fold but everyone
was talking about how Maxime is so not
really sure but okay crossing continues
nice to f3 with Bishop to g7 C captures
on d5 Knight captures on d5 II for we
have the main line Knight captures and
c3b captures and now c5 so everything
you know perfectly normal for for the
groom fold with Bishop to e3 and now
Queen to a5 threatening to Queen
captures in c3 we have Queen to d2 by
Magnus guarding the c3 pawn also maybe
in some cases Bishop to h6 can be played
you know exchanging the dark square
Bishop with Knight to c6 and now rook to
be one if the light square bishop is
developed you can capture on b7 and also
you want to get the the Queen side rock
away from a1 as soon as possible as if
the position opens up you don't want it
standing on a one as a target for for
blacks bishop
we have seek after some d4c capture
somebody for castles by Maxime and now
Magnus trades on a5 with Queen captures
Knight captures and now you do want to
play d5 at some point but if you play
it's too early I
it's not good because you you want to
keep this night on 85 that's the big
biggest weakness in blacks position if
you play d5 you take away this is c6
squared from last night and it is a very
nice idea but here while you can play
this Maxim already faced d5 in this
position he played it in 2016 and he won
a very nice game he continued ecigs just
attack the central right away and there
were no bigger issues with his position
so here Magnus continues with Bishop to
d3 Magnus doesn't just push a pawn and
Bishop to g4 Magnus castles in this
position and this position has been
reached before rook F to d8 is a no move
here b6 is a no move here just you know
get preventing this pawn from remaining
a target so maybe you can get the knight
back into the game via via b7 if not c6
but here Maxine goes Bishop captures on
f3 which can be described as extremely
risky because you're giving up the
bishop pair very early on in the game
the game is on both sides of the board
and you still have a knight and a5 which
could be an issue so let's see what
happens G captures on f3 by Magnus and
now II six of course Maxime doesn't want
to allow d5 we have rook F to be won by
Magnus and now rook F to d8 of course
you want to control the D file but
should back to f1 now the rook is also
guarding the the d4 pawn has the black
rook and black bears were attacking it
and here Maxine goes b6 and here what do
you play of course Maxime now wants to
get his night back into the game he
wants to try night a night to be 7 so
Magnus prevents it Bishop to e6 so a
very nice maneuver Bishop to f1 and back
to a6 here you of course now cannot use
the b7 squared to get your Knight back
into the game if you try knight c6 then
Bishop e7 just wins the game on the spot
so the night is still remaining on the
edge of the board so let's see what
happens
rook to d6 by maxing and now rook b2 c1
by Magnus the C file is the only open
file on the board so of course you want
to take advantage of that but here is
some you know just for the fun of it
here is some super engine sorcery
the engines give tink to g2 as as
rugby see one because here after King to
g2 and if black continues located the 80
you can play d5 now the point is after
each capture 75 you can go Bush up to g5
I tagged this rook and now whatever you
play if you play
Bishop to f6 c5 just wins you either win
this rook or the bishop or if the bishop
captures you win the rookin d8 or if you
don't block with the bishop if you play
f6 well then you just get blush up to f4
the rook has to move rook to c6 and or
if you go to the seventh and Bishop to
b5 we'll just take it away from the D
file same same idea he captures on d5
and now with the past deep on the the
bishop will simply be well very
successful in escorting the point of the
board so this is some super super engine
sorcery I just wanted to mention because
after Luke beat the c1 the same idea
doesn't work Maxime did go rook a to d8
but now you don't have the luxury of
going d5 because after captures and
Bishop g5 you can actually block with
Bishop to f6e v doesn't win now because
after Bishop captures on g5 your loop
and c1 is under attack that's why the
engines give King to g2 as a better line
than Ruby c1 but like I said it's super
engine sorcery Bishop to g5 now by
Magnus trying to weaken the blacks
position even more as if you move the
Ruby then you get Bishop to b5 so the
rook will eventually have to move from
the D file with f6 pushing the bishop
back Bishop to e3 and now h6 and here we
have a very interesting position all of
blacks pawns will not all of them but
most of them are now on the sixth rank
and if I had this position in a blintz
game in a bullet game in a hyperboloid
game I would I would immediately go rook
to c7 and it's interesting that I mean
what what other move is there other than
rook to c7 it seems like such a
wonderful move it's an open file you
want to get this rook all the way up
there attack the a7 pawn but here Magnus
took some 20-plus minutes to decide on
his next move and I was a very surprised
when the move was not rook to c7
now of course Magnus is the world
champion he didn't like rook to c7 for
some reason the problem was with which
rook to c7
you get nice too
see six defending the a7 pawn and then
after white attacks it for example d5
you get a capture Sun d5 rook captures
on d5 rook captures and eek a person b5
but now you get nice to be for d8 you
pawn is under attack the bishop on e6 is
under attack and also the d5 pawn is
under attack so you have to move the
Bishop Bishop c4 but now Knight captures
on d5 your Bishop on e3 is under attack
and well Magnus did not like where this
was going so here he did not go rook to
c7 as well he his position is better he
still has the bishop pair like I said
the game is on both sides of the board
you have to really take your time and
this is what you should always do when
you have a better position you should
take your time like I said he took over
20 minutes here and he played Bishop to
b5 so now if for example the same
variation happens night to be 4 at the
end of that variation will not come with
an attack on the bishop on e6 but also
you are now already controlling the d7
square so here at Magnus also has some
ideas of transferring the bishop over
for example to be four from where it
will kick away the rooks away from the D
file which is what Magnus wants to do so
he can push d5 crea create a path D pawn
and start really pushing for for the win
here but here maxime now also gets a his
saying this he pushes f5 now he forces
Magnus to decide whether he wants to
capture and if he wants to push d5 he
should do it now
so he does with d5 and now g5 by Maxine
we have Bishop to b2 now for the moment
you still cannot capture here so first
he captures only for with F captures on
e 4f captures on e4 and now a wonderful
idea it seems like you can win material
here and get rid of cross since pawns in
the center of the board but if you
capture the shop to be four will force
the rook to move and then again you will
get your passport here so here Maxime
finds a beautiful defensive resource and
that is a six and it is just a wonderful
idea where if Carsten captures an a6 for
example Bishop captures an a6
you get a cap for some d5 and our Bishop
to b4 is not a problem because well no
longer is the LightSquared Bishop here
so you don't control c6 or or or d7 so
you can go rook the c6 and now after
each capture 75
you can play rook captures on d5 and now
again white it does not have Bishop to
c4 to win the game because the knight
here also guards the c-4 square and even
if at some point you were to capture the
knight here then after pawn captures the
bishop on e6 is under attack so a six
just a beautiful defensive resource by
Maxime Bishop to a four by Carson of
course he doesn't capture and now he
captures on d5 by Maxine with Bishop to
b4 you have to make this sufficient soo
good work because well you first have to
free your rooks who can recapture on d5
we have grouped at least six and now
rook captures here attacking the rook
here so what do you do here best for
Maxine is just rook to b8 getting this
recorded way and not capturing and b5
and then for example after Bishop
captures pawn captures and rook the c4
defending this pawn here we get this
opposite color Bishop endgame which is
still very much playable but here Maxime
decided it was not a problem that he can
actually give cross in the past D pawn
he played rook captures on d5 with a
captures on d5 and now rook to e4 which
comes with an attack against the two
bishops here and this is what Maxime had
in mind he thought well I'm not gonna
tell you what he thought but feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
the absolute best move that Magnus
played in this position well I have a
nice sip of my water for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
I'm sure you've been brushing up on your
endgame skills and have found rook the
ch-check but this is what a Maxime had
in mind probably when he decided to give
Magnus the pass d5 point he thought that
if a3 now just defending the bishop
Danube the c-4 is super strong of course
you don't want to trade after rook to e1
you go Knight b7 and now after rook to
e8 check which is very nice you're gonna
go King t7u you still don't have the
shop to see to check because the rook is
guarding the CT square so Bishop to b3
rook the c1 check King to g2 and now
Bishop to f6 we'll just create
additional squares for the black King
you don't allow the rook to go to e7 to
try and pick up in the night here the
bishop and
regarding the d8 queening square and
black and maxime fights on but here
Karlsson plate looked the ch-check and
now you have problems you don't have the
option of going King h7 because Bishop
to see two wins the game on the spot so
King to f7 was played here by Maxine and
now comes a three but now it's really
really different because now rook to c4
as we've shown in the previous line is
met with butter up the e8 check and now
after King to f6 because the dark square
bishop does not allow the King here the
pond doesn't allow here the King to
enter the center of the board so King to
f6 but now rook to b8 you still don't
you still don't trade of course and now
the bishop the bishop and the rook are
controlling all the three squares that
white needs to promote the point d6 d7
and d8 is coming so after a three Maxime
played Bishop to e5 to grab holdings of
some very important squares but now
crossing goes Bishop the e8 similar like
in the previous line King to g7 now and
now just d6 he starts pushing his past
pawn which is what you want to do most
of the times
rook the d4 and now just d7 the threat
of course is d8 as white already defends
the the d8 square so Knights the b7 now
controlling the D a square with the rook
and with the night but cross and goes
Bishop to e7 brings another defender to
the d8 square here and now maxime rook
to e4 which shows how much of a fighting
spirit he has he still finds poison in
the position because here if cross and
just you know brings the Queen into the
game he doesn't really care then you get
captures and after captures here you get
Bishop captures and h2 so muttsy would
still grab a little bit material for the
piece and here you would have 4 points
against 2 points so 2 points for the
piece you still can't capture here as
the route would be hanging so even
though white is winning here you would
really really have to work for your meal
so crossing not in Russia plays rook to
c6 now just gets through card wait
threatens to win more material here and
kick away this night from defending the
d8 square and now again magnus doesn't
care about Bishop captures because after
recap
only seven you just play rook capture
some b6 the knight is under attack
ninety-eight rook to b8 and now there's
no more play for black here if you move
the knight 96 now just queen the pawn
and after Knight captures the rook
captures but now it's three to two
points only one point for a piece
completely winning four for white so
here push up to d4 defending the beasts
exponent but now as the bishop left the
defense of the c7 square now Magnus
plays rook to c7 and it was in this
position that maxime beaugeois graphic
design/credits pretty pointless as after
Luke captures here there's no stopping
here the bishop is helpless to help out
with the defense of the d8 square
nothing to do there so what you can do
Bishop c5 but now after white gets a
queen you can capture here but it's a
queen and bishop against the rook and
Bishop of course it's not even not even
a little bit dangerous for white
so after rook to c7 of course maxime
knows it's over and really just a
wonderful wonderful win against the
roomful defense by world champion Magnus
Carlsen and this makes it I don't know
probably Carlson's eight classical win
in a row or something like that and he's
not up there yet to his former glory he
will not break his former rating record
which I believe is 2889 or something
like that but you know he's getting very
close to it and it will be well it's
just gonna be very interesting to see
how far he can go and he finished this
tournament with plus five which is
insane because this is probably the
strongest tournament where he finished
with such a good result as he mentioned
in the tournament in the interview after
the game there were no Outsiders here
only the absolute you know top elite
players of the world so no no guests you
know some twenty twenty six hundred
twenty-five fifty hundred players which
is well just all the more impressive so
as he came into the last round as the
sole leader of the tournament by him
winning this game means that he also
wins the tournament so even if Wesley
wins the game against uh Bernard and he
does not have that chance to catch up to
Magnus so the Christian Grantchester
is now over I don't have all the results
but we are going to show at least one
more game from from the final round and
then we're gonna show the be complete
standings but probably tomorrow morning
so that's that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it and really just you know now
we can learn a lot from this how Maxime
allowed this pawn to be promoted into a
into a pasty pawn and then the bishop
repair was used to such a you know such
a degree to escort the pawn of the board
I was just amazing I always enjoy when
you know something like that happens but
yeah once again I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank me how Bogard for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it I don't if
you haven't checked out the game between
my nephew and Gary cause part of it will
be the first link in the description you
will see so if you haven't seen it do
check it out it's really an awesome game
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content checking company or suggestions
we are now going back to the Capablanca
saga and so on and so on thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your Sunday